welcome to crunchy rolls first ever and
so it looks like crunch we're all
hosting an anime Wars and this is
actually a fun little idea you know
because here in the Western and having
anything close to an official award
ceremony so you know it won't be a
hundred percent accurate but it'll be
fun now you see that's what the anime
awards are all about it's not about who
won or lost it's about a group of anime
fans coming together to celebrate
everything they know what the [ __ ] this
is [ __ ] put the outlet Shoppes and
welcome to the 2016 crunchyroll anime
Awards calm down guys start off this
year with the best girl category and I
really have no idea who's gonna win this
and let's see who what oh it was Ram Run
one basket of the year everyone oh my
god
shut up guys I think this time we can
actually get a few words my winner
though hi I'm here with the winner of
this year's award for best girl
as I'm sure she's going to be very
excited to accept this award so miss how
do you feel about winning this year's
award for best girl I didn't win best
girls Ram won best girl whoo and of
course the best animation award go shoes
hilarious where the grill drum of the
year this year goes over through em
right sister k-rock ago found that the
corners crying on that boy go through
Eureka Sookie from URI or night hey okay
there's couple go through URI and Victor
from URI on all of a second are all
these spot in category can be hearing or
nice yeah oh yay most heartwarming scene
jury on ice that's opening URI on ice
best ending during on ice but why stop
there guys best man service URI on ice
most big socks in an anime Yuri on ice
best port full color Yuri on I bet Yuri
on ice free Colonel summer alright you
can go [ __ ] yourself and I think now
would be a good son see how the rest of
the can easier taking this hey you know
any to feel the awards given watch he
deserves
I mean ducky won best hero Bob psycho
got best action and best fight scene and
yes
best comedy this year deservedly went
through the grunty roll anime Awards
[Applause]
then we get the villain of the year
which is of course going to be clearer
from Jojo I mean there's literally no
better choice this year than care of the
JoJo's I mean like
we can we cut the commercial break make
cuts cut to commercial
cut to commercial [ __ ] Dan decide
solar and wind could solve be the
amazing energy source of the future salt
tears of the earth all right I'm back
guys I'm back we don't have much longer
today but before I leave you or do you
want to hear a joke your taste in animes
thank you very much I will see you all
next year
all right crunchyroll let's have a
little serious talk about these award I
can see what you were going for and
these awards did seem like a fun little
idea if done correctly but there was
always going to be a problem hosting an
award show designed to showcase the best
of anime coming out in the previous year
decided entirely by popular vote and boy
did that problem rare is had in these
results even the nomination system you
had before with your judges submitting
Blinds nominations was always going to
see you nominations towards popularity
before voting it even begun and as much
as there are some unexpected nominations
and well with nominations the vast pool
of anime last year was definitely not
represented personally I do not think a
popular vote should be the entire basis
of an award ceremony like this because I
think a lot of us who have watched more
animes and urea and ice last year can
safely say the most these winners are
not actually the best things come out of
their categories but instead are just
the most popular shows in their
respective categories there is a lot of
potential here and I hope there is a
better system next year and hey my doors
are always open just saying not enough
of the negative to offset all the salt
that's being thrown around I thought I'd
host my own anime Awards and I hope
everyone will be able to agree with
here of the year whoever had a legendary
oscar-winning actors Sir Ian McKellen in
the interview room and was just like
yeah can you read out this weep [ __ ]
please villain of the year
Donald J Trump's best fight scene Iran
may versus their own mods when shelter
got taken down most heartwarming scene
madhouse breaking their curse and
announcing one punch man season two best
couple crunchyroll explanimation the
match made in heaven best boy yet
another JoJo's reference that came out
last year best girl that was only ever
going to be won best comedy Malick
Obama's Twitter page best animation this
really realistic lifelike volleyball
feed from high Q's Olympics Ark drama of
the year the rise and fall of
leafyishere
that's opening McLaury gospel singing
the Evangelion theme best ending the
brexit results and anime of the year
undoubtedly goes to 2016 itself for
being by far the most entertaining
things to come out in decade and that
was it for the gig Academy Awards of
2016 before II although I don't know why
people getting so riled up a crunch role
for these anime Award results if
anything it's just proven something that
we've all known for a very long time
that everyone but you have [ __ ] taste
[Music]
[Music]